how are you doing today
i'm great i'm just great steve thank you
uh i am a big fan of c uh and i've seen
the first three episodes of season two
i'm all in plenty of things i want to
talk to you about but uh before getting
into c i'm always curious uh
when did you feel like you made it as an
actor where you could pay rent just from
acting
[Laughter]
um well i had the great
good fortune of a father who supported
me
uh
until i could pay rent and actually a
bit he supported me
well after i could pay rent because you
know when your dad or mom and
you just want to stay connected he would
say things to me like well you better
take it while i've got it so um
i never i never thought of the salary as
the fact that
that i
was an adult and i could take care of
myself in this industry and i know that
is such a such a blessing
uh it is if you can believe it 25 years
since star trek first contact
uh yeah i know it's it's crazy uh and as
a big star trek fan i am curious what do
you remember from the making of that
film mother do you have any strong
memories
yes i do i have scars here
because
jonathan frakes who
uh is my godson yes we are he might even
be a month older than me or i'm a month
old than he is but um
he asked me to to to do it now i i was
good friends with jonathan of course
with lavar and a lot of people
on the set on brent but i had never
really kept up with it so when he he
called me asked me when i said okay
great and i'll make this quick but
i i got the script and i was reading it
it just read like action and i said oh
yeah this is so cool
and so
it says i was you know coming out of
jeffrey's tubes and i say well now who's
jeffrey and they say uh you don't need
to know it's like
because there's a huge explosion that we
practiced for about five hours it was uh
um
jamie
and i and
me and jamie and probably
200
stunt people when the explosion happens
when when the first contact when the
borders are hitting the board yet you
know hitting that outpost
and we're supposed to just
jump up in the air turn around in the
air and land so the cameras could hit us
right there with and getting this jolt
and we we practiced it for hours and
hours and then when it happened
the explosion was so intense it just
knocked us off our butts we you know we
just fell any way we could but i managed
to get my face up and jamie had his face
right there and we said the line and so
i ran to jonathan all my my arms were
bleeding and all the skin was gone
that obviously the costume was ripped up
and he i said jonathan i i
messed up the costume and my arms are
bleeding his that's okay we've got it
and he walked away
that's so that's the memory that i that
i have on first contact
uh yeah i think that maybe
that obviously stunt was went a little
awry but i i think that people don't
realize that maybe making movies and tv
isn't as glamorous as they think
nothing
even the most mundane thing is not
glamorous it's tough
it is yeah
it's tough
uh as i said jumping into c uh
like i said earlier i'm a big fan and
i've a lot of people have spoken to when
they're working on the second season of
a series they've learned a lot on the
making the first series that they carry
with them you know what they can and i'm
just curious what did you learn making
the first season if anything that maybe
helped you in season two
um i almost don't separate the seasons
because i discovered a character uh and
and i discovered a tribe and and a way
of working in a whole world so
we i don't separate the seasons
we just got to continue living and uh
and in continuing living the focus uh
came more to
the relationships within the family and
the past relationships of family coming
coming back to haunt or to be finally
dealt with and that's what's happening
so there's a there's a lot of more
intensity if you can believe it in
season two a lot of just
passions unleashed because it's family
and family is the place where you
you love the most and you get hurt the
most and you strike back the hardest
in the episodes i saw more is revealed
about your character without getting
specific and i'm curious when you signed
on for the series how much were you told
about like the the full arc of the show
and what might be happening and how much
are you finding out script by script
well you find out uh i find out um
at the top of a season
um i i know at the start of a season
where i'm going uh
what the full arc is and
we take whatever arc that was and where
where you want to go by the end of this
next season
um
and then you might make some adjustments
because you always have to there's new
visions new ideas but you still have to
make them uh
sort of
contiguous with
what you've already established as the
world because
because that's an honest way of working
but also you owe it to your viewership i
think
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of series and
movies what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of sea
that they might not know
we are seriously in the wilderness
we are freezing cold we are sopping wet
we are sometimes up to our shins and mud
we fall down we cut ourselves
we get bitten
sometimes we don't go to the loo for
five or six hours because
you just you know you got on a bunch of
gear and you gotta traipse through
the forest and the mud to get there and
you just can't drop trout right there
because then things will bite your bum
and
it is uh it's like um remember that
thing they used to have i hope they
still had it called outward bound
um it is a program for for kids that
might be a little frisky and they take
you out and and you have to live and you
come to understand more about yourself
and what you're capable of in your
character by being out in the wilderness
so
it's like that there's no we have to
shoot
we we can't and most of the time there's
no
wi-fi which is lovely known reception so
you're really just out there together it
really is um
an expedition
well i but i think that that
that makes this is part of the reason
why the series is so awesome to watch
because it looks incredible with these
real locations it looks like you're cold
it's not you know a pretend
yeah
it's the kind of thing
when you come in
at the end of the day i don't set off to
go to act
i know what i'm supposed to do and i
know what's required what i want to
accomplish uh emotionally beat by beat i
know what that is because i read it but
once you once you step out of the car
and you're out there falling down
you know ripping stuff but ripping parts
of your body open
i i'm really just trying to stay on my
feet and stay alive until the end of the
day and sometimes you start saying okay
maybe if i hurt myself bad enough
they'll take me to the hospital and i
can sleep and get warm for a few hours
i'm almost out of time with you but i
wanted to ask about something else uh
i'm a big fan of the russo brothers and
i know you worked on gray man um what
was it like being part of that because i
know that's a massive massive movie
it is massive uh i had this fabulous
apartment uh my character look that's
the first thing i think about we all
went on about how we would love to have
this apartment her apartment is in uh in
the czech republic um and
that's that's so neither here nor there
but that's what i one of the things i
think of i so enjoyed ryan
and um and anna
and and the boys it was it was lovely i
had to do a stunt though
that i feel so miserably at it also
because i kept giggling that i couldn't
do it but um it involved me
you know
there's a big huge blast and
you know i i have to like crab
swim out of this
this
demolished area and it was just
i was terrible at it i was swimming in
place
and but it was exciting because um
yeah
i wanted to do something like that i was
unfortunately when i signed on as i saw
oh hong kong oh thailand oh you know all
these different places
and i was on long i was on location and
freaking not free i was on location in
beautiful long beach which is like 20
minutes from my house which i love when
i just want to go down and
do the long beach thing and hang because
you know long beach is all right
but uh i thought i was going to travel
the world i went to long beach
because of covet
i completely understand i got to stop i
could ask you a million other things i
just want to say thank you so much and
seriously uh c is fantastic i'm a huge
fan of the series thank you i appreciate
you you're really you're really gonna be
blown away